all right hello and welcome everyone it
is Saturday August 26 2023 and we're
here in physics as information
processing in the fourth discussion
thank you everybody who's joining live
or watching live or watching and replay
this should be a really fun discussion
as usual
so we're gonna have under provide some
slides and some initial clarifying
questions for Chris and then we're gonna
open it up for our guests to ask some
questions and check in a live chat see
what people are talking about so honor
to you for some slides and overview
okay thank you Daniel so um last time we
were starting to to talk about
multi-agent communication and log
protocols and all of that so let's
quickly growth go through the slides and
uh sort of try to recall the main
Concepts
so
um I guess from
just to go back uh to session three for
a second uh one takeaway was that when
you have non-comedian sectors in a
boundary that's necessarily going to
require
classical communication between them so
that is more or less the whole point of
today uh how non-commune sectors May
communicate have to communicate
classically
um
another uh introduction in in this last
lecture was uh
this new graphical notation uh tqft if
you wish to call it that way for any of
these clock tips okay so so let's recall
the the whole process of uh measuring a
sector environment and writing it into a
memory environment it can be simplified
to this sort of tick the connect uh
connects to two two portions of the
boundary and you know uh
everything we talk about log protocols
will be will be written in this
graphical notation
um
so
let's keep going a little bit uh
it's on the paper on uh sequential
measurements from 20 2022 uh these are
basically the the formal mapping between
qrfs and uh
topological Quantum field theories okay
so we're more used used to the picture
here on the left hand side of this slide
right with with the qrf sectors but you
know
rhetorically speaking this is at least
how they map
um
okay and then uh from then uh we started
talking about entanglement and classical
Communications
using this notation and and this is
probably where my questions to Chris
will will start
uh so in section three uh we saw
this idea of the fvp asymptotically
being the principle of unitarity AKA
driving the system the join system Alice
involved uh to entanglement which in the
graphical notation amounts to them sort
of uh completing a a cycle here where
the QRS are perfectly aligned so that
the S sector of one becomes the memory
sector of the other and vice versa now I
actually at this point already I have a
question uh for for Chris I mean I have
written down here
um
so
so yes two things here uh Chris
number one uh is
um
in in the in the log protocol picture we
do have a distinguishing between a
Quantum Channel and a classical Channel
and if I understood that part correctly
we said that
passage of time or expenditure of energy
free energy only corresponds to the
classical tick so in this you know
quantum entanglement picture where you
don't quite have that it is it fair to
say that there's no such thing as as a
classical take no passage of time no
expenditure free energy is this a
degenerate picture of the log protocol
where the sectors were aligned the right
way
and boom you got rid of that classical
thing
and and that's it and secondly I guess
it's what does it mean for these two
parts quote unquote uh from the paper to
implement a joint uh unitary process you
join Quantum process
so yeah this is this is not a lock
protocol clearly because uh there there
is no classical uh communication
and and in fact uh Alice
is not divided into uh multiple
compartments here
uh Alice is just implementing one this
this single Quantum process Q
and uh
because these sectors are are because
these These qrfs are perfectly aligned
oh
we can think of
of
a a pro remember uh
probably the second session
the the the
picture that you were very interested in
under
how
of the wick rotation
uh
reversing time between Alice and Bob so
Ellis's clock in fact
uh ticks in the opposite direction from
Bob's clock because both of their
internal clocks are counting incoming
bits not outgoing bits
so in this in the right side of this
picture
um
there there is no overall time
you can think of
Alice's clock uh ticking forward one
unit
and then Bob's clock ticking backward
one unit
so that uh
the the information flow is completely
time symmetric between Alice and Bob
so we can think of of both of these
processes q and Q Prime
as bi-directional in time
that's that's what it means to have a
pure unitary process well
um
so no time I symmetry that's what it is
right so there is no time asymmetry in
this picture and once when you introduce
classical communication of course you
have to have a Time asymmetry right
because uh you have this I mean
classicality is defined by this notion
of irreversibility
which is just the same as As Time
asymmetry and it's the irreversibility
that burns energy so the
there has to be energy flow between
Alice and Bob
uh
to to drive
what is in from a global point of view
and only an apparent asymmetry but from
the point of view of
Alice 1 and Alice 2 as components of
Alice
oh they're the ones who see the
asymmetry
so I guess uh just to tie back to the
question of the weak rotation once this
joint uh process is implemented I mean
and iFly one can say is this cycle going
clockwise or counterclockwise and it's
is that going to Define on
originally whenever this guy's ended up
being lined up where the weak sign was
coming from
of
yes whenever
whenever Alice sees information flowing
in Bob sees information flowing out so
there
their their Wick rotations they're going
out opposite directions
okay
yeah uh very good
and uh yeah the other the other thing to
to think of in this picture which is
it's impossible to draw all of these
simultaneously is that if you if you
think of the fep
as
fully aligning Alice and Bob
then not only do these processes
perfectly couple
but the the area that's green
uh in this right hand side kind of
expands to fill the whole boundary so
that in the in the complete limit
of uh
Alice being able to perfectly predict
Bob and and vice versa then the whole
boundary is green right so the uh
there's no this distinction between
the the S sector and the Y sector
disappears
yes yes that makes sense actually and
just to conclude with this slide
um back in the session two we saw
something about uh agents requiring a
free choice of reference frame for their
qrfs which amounts to being able to
choose how to measure a spin right
right so it's part of this entanglement
picture like do they do they just have
to align the sectors or also the way
they are measuring a spin on those
sectors
yes they they they have to align the way
they're measuring the spin in those
sectors that it's that lack of remember
the the point that
uh
free choice of of
local reference frame
is required for separability
so as the systems become fully entangled
then their local reference frames for
each qubit
I'll become the same
that might become necessarily the same
thank you okay and then uh let's
continue a little bit
um so in in this in this talk we're
mainly interested uh uh krfs that do not
commute
uh now maybe uh you can of course you
can tie this back
to what you were saying earlier about if
you're perfectly entangled then the the
sector is going to grow does it have
anything to do with this so if q1 and Q2
here are
do commute then how does how do you
reduce this uh to the picture on the
right hand side
at the first class it looks like the
picture on the left hand side
encompasses uh more sectors of the
binary
yeah the the point here is just that if
if we go back and
go back to the notation where
uh
what we're we're representing by this
this simplified notation
is a
collection of
uh
cone cocone diagrams
and if the if the
if these reference frames commute
then
one can take these two diagrams
and
and find a
uh think of it in the information inflow
Direction
uh there will always be a common
uh Co
cone
over the two sets of
input classifiers
if the two qrfs commute
so what that means is that I go from a
diagram with two sets of of classifiers
each going up to some Apex
to a diagram with the merge set of
classifiers going up to some
some farther up the hierarchy Apex
because they commute I can find that
that
sort of yet more abstract cocone that
covers all of the classifiers in both
qrfs
so that just collapses
of these pairs of green segments down to
one green segment and I've drawn it the
same size I mean it would it would make
more sense graphically I suppose to draw
it right each one is twice as big or as
each one is the area
but yeah keeping to this kind of very
topological representation where the
area
isn't actually meaningful
um it is convenient to draw it this way
right
the fact that the commute means that you
will have that higher Apex in a way so
you can bypass that that first nesting
right but it comes to the number of
degrees of freedom the boundary uh
they're still the same and in terms of
their yeah right okay yeah we're not
we're not getting rid of any of the the
degrees of freedom of the boundary that
these uh curves are looking at
uh yeah very good so the next slide
um I found a very interesting one so
these are no growth theorems things that
Alex and Bob cannot do and they may you
know it's mainly having to do about
measuring their own entangled I meant
entropy and Counting degrees of freedom
um
I guess uh this has uh a very
holographic feel to it and also maybe
even a bit of a godo theorem feel to it
so I don't know if Chris wants to
comment on that
well I'll just say that I I think this
does have a kind of
how
girdle undecidability feel to it and
that there there are a large number of
questions that Alice can't answer
which uh certainly suggests a
formulation in terms of incompleteness
and this is
the connection to girdle's theorem is
actually something that Jim glazebrook
and I are currently working on
um and hopefully we'll be able to make
that connection more precise
but the the point of these statements is
just to emphasize that
um
a single Observer
that's uncompartmentalized
cannot uh determine anything about the
entanglement entropy of the environment
and this is this is just the result that
to to measure entanglement you have to
have you have to employ a lot protocols
so you have to have classical
communication
and
this
raises of
a fundamental issue in the theory and
that that I'll classical communication
is
an exchange of information
that
cannot be represented as a single
Quantum process you know hence
you have language like the collapse of
the wave function or these various other
uh you know deed coherence etc etc these
various ways of trying to capture this
idea that
something different and irreversible is
happening
as soon as you talk about classical
communication
so
uh
the point is for for Alice to measure
anything about the entanglement entropy
of Bob she has to be sectored
uh so her entanglement entropy has to
decrease
but she can't know that she can't
actually know that she has sector
compartments when we think of Alice as
an entire system
so
from now on
we're going to be talking about
the very limited points of view of
particular Observers
and to to talk about that I think it's
it's very important to keep these
various limitations in mind
because there's a real
distinction between
what we can say
uh effectively
from this kind of God's eye point of
view that we're adopting as theorists
where we say uh
Alice has
sectors that are communicating
classically
and
uh what
Alice A system can do from her point of
view
or
uh her sectors can do from their points
of view this is a distinction that's
often ignored but it's important to keep
it in mind
awesome thanks for this lion
enter
yeah so
before we continue
um
so then uh I guess if we get to the the
proper material of of the last lecture
which is what happens when you have
sectors
that are not commutative such as two
portions of this involved that have to
communicate classically
this this is what requires the classical
communication tick
um
let me see uh
so it would be fair to say Chris uh this
only such a classical Channel which is
the one shown in this uh slide requires
free energy
is that right because there's some
writing into a memory involved in here
compared to the earlier slide where we
had that closed loop in the entangled
picture there was no expenditure of
energy is that correct
right
right so so here the the the example
that came to mind here is
um exactly the process that we're that
we're executing right now
um
Alice has two components
um and and we are currently in the
position of those components
and we're communicating classically with
each other
by uh employing a channel that's part of
our shared environment
so we're acting
irreversibly on our shared environment
and
it's that irreversible action on the
environment that has the free energy
cost for each of us
we actually have to make noise
to communicate
and uh
you know our our laptops are actually
consuming power
all of this is classical I mean it's
this irreversible
irreversibility that defines
classicality
right and uh to continue with this
question I guess
uh it'll come in short in in later
slides but the other side of this lock
protocols is the Quantum Channel and my
question to you uh Chris is just like
there is an expenditure of time and
energy involved in this classical
Channel
this is the Quantum Channel basically
the opposite of that meaning it's it's
it's on it's action is instantaneous
entanglement presumably and also again
back to that Loop picture of the
entangle cycle uh is there just no
passage of time no expenditure of energy
is does that any of that make sense
uh yeah and I think it's worth actually
going to the next slide here where we
complete the loop and add the quantum
Channel
um
is it is it this one yeah
I think to to understand what's going on
here
I think it's very useful to think of it
in terms of uh of the lepr experiment
right where
um
Bob in this case the shared environment
includes the source that's creating the
entangled pair
which of A1 and A2 observe
simultaneously
they interact simultaneously with
their two detectors which are
interacting with the entangled pair so
you can think of their their two
detectors are entangled
and it's only later
that they exchanged this classical
information
and in a bell APR experiment
the
the time the elapsed time between the
source emitting the entangled pair
and the entangled pair interacting with
um
the detectors deployed by A1 and A2
is
is designed as part of the experimental
protocol to be less
than the time that it is required for A1
and A2 to communicate classically
and notice that from the point of view
of the entangled pair itself no time has
passed at all
right it's
the integral pair is
from a special relativity point of view
uh moving along a light light trajectory
so there's
uh there's no distance being traversed
in no time is is elapsing
from the point of view of the entangled
pair
uh there's only an elapsed time
and a Traverse distance in the
coordinates of The Observers
and it's those coordinates that Define
the parameters for the observer's
eventual classical communication
so that's this is why I characterize the
the Assumption of classical
communication as a stipulation
and also why I characterized it as a
fine-tuning assumption right we're
we're
assuming something very specific about
this communication Channel
uh and we're assuming that
the part of Bob the part of the shared
environment
that implements this classical
Communication channel
behaves differently from the rest of the
shared environment
it behaves in a way that is is classical
uh but the rest of the shared
environment doesn't
right the rest of the world is is
described using quantum theory so we're
we're making this assumption that part
of the shared environment is special
and the the specialness is that it it
behaves in this classical way
so let me let me finish with this uh
slide I suppose uh
to go back to my earlier question about
that entangled Loop being
at least rhetorically appears to be like
a degenerate version of this log picture
if in this lot of picture I have the
quantum channel on the right
uh that
hypothetical entanglement on the to
complete the cycle on the left was only
broken when A1 and A2
chose to write
that into their memories at different
sectors right and then that eventually
necessitated the classical communication
between them is that is that correct
yeah
um
you know one could
one could always take the point of view
of
uh if you will The Observer who's
outside the entire universe
and just sees the entire universe
evolving unitarily
and in from that point of view there's
no such thing as classical communication
so the communication is classical only
only relative to this division between
The Observers
and that division between The Observers
corresponds to their their measurement
procedures not commuting
so it it corresponds to what we think of
classically
as Alice acting on her half of the
entangled state
uh determining what Bob will then see
again that's that all of that causal
language is classical
right
uh and we're like at 11 30 so halfway
more or less let's say a few words on
uh the later slide but still uh it's
getting profits and all of that
um
I guess before we before we start
talking about this which will take us
like
five to ten minutes at most would you
say if you a few words again about the
fine-tuning Assumption so uh I still
can't quite understand what it's meant
here that this whole classical
communication staff requires fine-tuning
okay I I think uh a way to think about
it
is
um
to
to think about what it means to say that
Alice and Bob are able to communicate
classically
um
what we're saying is that Alice and Bob
share some sort of language so when they
exchange their data
we can think of their data as as written
in some binary code in a data table
you know Alice says
I I set my instrument this way and I saw
this Spin and I I then set my instrument
this other way and I made this
observation
so Alice's data table or a1's data table
um is is just a a long table with two
entries in each row
one entry is
how the detector was adjusted and the
other entry is is what the value of the
spin was observed
and Bob's data table looks the same
and so they they share this information
or they share it with some third party
they they communicate it classically
and there are two aspects to that
classical communication one is that
up to classical noise
of their data tables don't change
when they share them
so uh they really are irreversibly
recorded they're not evolving in time
uh along with the rest of the universe
the other aspect is that we have to
assume that Alice and Bob mean the same
thing
uh
by
their their notations in these data
tables so that they can actually compare
them so that they can actually do the
statistics
and see if they've violated Bell's
inequality
so what that means is we have to assume
that they actually share a definition of
up
and that when they talk about changing
the settings on their instruments
they're talking about changing those
settings with respect to some shared
definition of up
and you know in a in a real experiment
that shared definition of up is provided
by the the Earth's gravitational field
or something like that
Earth's magnetic field
some shared environmental variable
so now it seems like oh
we have a situation in which Alice Alice
1 and LS2 should be entangled right
because they share this reference frame
that enables them to communicate
classically
but
they can't be entangled if they're going
to communicate classically
so
so we make an assumption
that in just this case
they share a reference frame but they're
not entangled
they're able they're able to communicate
classically while sharing the reference
rate
and
we can sort of wave our hands and say uh
they only share the reference frame up
to some measurement resolution or
something like that
but
despite the hand waving we're making a
very specific assumption
that
violates
oh
the fact that reference frame sharing uh
induces entanglement so that's the
fine-tuning assumption
we assume that the universe is such that
in this very specific kind of case
uh we can have reference frame sharing
without entanglement
let's let's keep it here and just open
it up a little bit if um Harris or Dean
want to just get any thought or
reflection on what we've gotten to so
far
Paris if you want to please
yes everything is very interesting
um basically I was listening
with great let's say focus it reminded
me this let's say elaboration on the
previous talk that Chris gave two weeks
ago it reminded me something that
Michael Levin said some time ago
it is regarding this amazing ability of
uh cognition to scale up
so it's not only
this understanding let's say of the
scattering of cognition but also the
scaling up of cognition and when I try
to get inside in my head
actually that
asked Chrisette in in one of his talks
that if a system is a toggle one cannot
draw a meaningful boundary across it so
these fine fine tuning let's say
elaboration that was made
right now actually helps me understand
that even better so thank you Chris for
that and thank you under for this
collaboration
well thank you thank you I'm glad that
helped
yeah I I think this is intimately
related to
the question of what cognition is
oh
since if if we have a if we have a
purely Quantum system
there there really is a deep sense in
which nothing is happening because of
the time symmetry
so to talk about cognition is something
that actually occurs
uh we have to think of it classically
thank you also if you allow me another
comment on that and basically one of the
comments posted during your last talk in
the chat had to do with classical
memories and I was thinking about that
and I I came to the conclusion that
classical memories presupposes a
gestation period
and and when I think that about it that
actually makes sense and it is true
let's say uh for for both physical and
psychological reasons so uh for example
a hard disk needs to write data on its
magnetic surface and a human brain needs
to consolidate all those neural
connections through
synaptic plasticity let's say however
when we start thinking about quantity
Quantum information
and Quantum
Quantum memories let's say we realize
that such memories will be such Quantum
memories basically will be stored in
qubits or in those and toggle states
that you described so the end do not
necessarily have the same limitations
and of course
Quantum information theories suggests as
I understand it that Quantum memories
can be created and accessed
instantaneously without any form of
gestation let's say without any
gestation period and of course this goes
back and it has the potential as I see
to revolutionize computation with in
terms of quantum Community computation
but also and most importantly
communication and and Quantum
cryptography even and this is something
that I
I am truly interested
so yeah I just wanted to share also that
[Music]
yeah that's that's a very good point
um
and the the flip side is
the the issue of stability
which again gets to the notion of of
Environmental decoccurrence
which is just the process of observation
of the quantum state by uh some
environment or some Observer some
component of its environment
and uh the reason this is a problem in
practice is that we don't have complete
control of all components of the
environment
right
uh so
we have to use things like liquid helium
to try to keep the environment at Bay to
prevent decoherence
uh because any other components of the
environment interacting with our Quantum
memory will alter the state of the
memory
yeah that is uh that is a great
ingredients
and basically the reason why I type that
question regarding
super selection rules and namely I
propose something called fuzzy super
selection rules
basically as I understand those super
selection rules the classical let's once
let's say they are based on symmetries
or on on all those conversation laws
they'll actually limit the accessibility
over there our capacity to to measure
let's say certain Quantum properties
let's say maybe it's parity maybe it's
angular momentum maybe it's even charged
but if we if we start thinking like uh
this fuzzy super selection rules
in an effort to relax these restrictions
by allowing some degree of coherence or
interference between the different super
selected sectors which can be a
Quantified let's say by a parameter
called fossils I know that in other
words like in my field that is fuzzy
Cooperative mapping the production of
fastiness
from us as it was propounded by
Professor lotfi is that it actually
helped a lot of our models to become a
more accurate let's say so this is uh
what I am proposing maybe of course I I
don't expect it to
revolutionize Quantum information but
maybe it can help us understand a bit
better what is going on in the role of
this the coherence that comes out of the
environment so if we incorporate it as a
parameter of fuzziness a priori then
maybe can understand and even
what we are dealing with
uh yeah
um
I I would refer you to the paper Vibe
Bartlett
um two or the other there are two other
co-authors
in 2007
uh a lovely review of quantum reference
frames in reviews of modern physics
and a point that they make that I think
is relevant here
is that a super selection rule
can always be interpreted
let me see if I if I I'm not sure I'll
be able to completely reproduce their
argument
but they showed that a super selection
rule can always be interpreted as the
absence of a reference frame or the the
lack of a reference frame
and one of the examples that they give
is
um charge conservation
that we never see
uh
superpositions of different electric
charges
and uh their point is we never see this
because we have no way of measuring it
we have no reference frame
that we could use
that would allow us to see a state of of
superposed charges
and effectively what they're saying is
our reference frames are all made of
matter
that uh is is that is composed of stuff
that has well-defined electric charges
so we can't we can't see things that are
superpositions of charge and it's very
difficult you know for us to see things
that are super positions if positioned
so
this question of
what
is a super selection rule why do we have
these rules
at least in their reasoning
boils down to the question of why do we
have some
reference frames or sun measurement
capabilities and not others what is it
about us
that
limits in some fundamental way our
ability to make measurements
and
I suspect that when you talk about
fuzziness which is a sense of of
classical uncertainty
that you may be
um
sort of pointing in that direction
but I think I think it would be worth
looking at that paper and
which is which is largely written in
English right the the formalism is oh
wow
so it's a it's a very nice paper
okay thank you
for sure thank you
um Andrew maybe mute a little bit Dean
on the Mountaintop
what can you throw down on us
everything super special throw down I I
have a I have a question though and
because I am very comfortable in that
fuzzy space I kind of see relationships
as
uh and their and their lack of
definability as a feature so here's my
here's kind of my question
um
so you talked about a minimum sort of
two different memories to encode
something a time and I think it's it was
one of the slides just after the one
that's up here right now
which sounds to me like somewhere
processing capacity it sounds like we
are kind of stepping back
and trying to look at this instantaneous
thing
from the relative position of even the
things that are classical can be seen as
all Quantum so that when you mentioned
that earlier Chris that helped me quite
a bit
which then manifests itself as a
classical ability to process somewhere I
I spent a lot of my career
self-labeling as a wayfinder
so not capacity realization relationship
just as a relationship it means that
wave binding is not just an orienting or
a processing where I am
and being gripped by the sort of the
things I'm enveloped by it's also the
channel the screen the bound the divide
the Gap the unentangled potentiator
it's the thing upon which traction can
exist as being a gripper as well
so if it's
I was already hung up on I wanted to go
back like Colombo in that old 70s TV
show and talk about z-spin because I
think z-spin is an energy way of
describing but I honestly think when I
went back and watched the your
presentation a couple of times I'm
starting to get a sense
that z-spin is also relationship it's
that affordance
that allows us to be able to see up and
down but I'm just curious Chris are we
really talking about
processing somewhere in the classical
sense
but because we have these two ways of
encoding different memories we're also
talking about somewhere processing just
that
that state that allows for
that that's my my question is that what
we're really getting are we are we
trying to open that up that possibility
up
uh yeah I I think that's a nice way to
think about it
um
I think we're trying to at some deep
level
uh
come up with a way of describing
what it means to be
an agent
uh and I'll say in our our case of
self-conscious agent
uh with a sense of time
that's embedded in an environment
that we depend on to store memories for
us
and what I what I mean by that is that
we we depend on
the environment
to
change very slowly at least from our
point of view
so that we can
keep some sense of our orientation
within the environment
right we're using
everything we see as a memory
that allows us to keep our
ourselves fixed which allows us to have
a point of view
so we're we're using the entire visible
environment as if you will a reference
frame
uh against which we can see small
changes
but if the environment was constantly
changed constantly and rapidly changing
we wouldn't be able to do that and we
wouldn't
be able to use it as a memory and so we
would have no point of view
so in a sense I think what we're talking
about here is the
um
kind of of the the miracle of having a
point of view that gives us a sense of
time
that's very philosophical that
it's it's amazing and I wonder if along
with the perspectival visual
advancements which you and Shannon
Dobson have explored in the math art
settings
you're almost bringing that kind of a
transformative re-understanding or
re-quantum reference framing
into a temporal
setting where it's not just a static
spatial parallax
that we are
aesthetically and formally
re-understanding but also a temporal one
which in an agent environment system
necessitates these questions of
communication
which in the quantum information
formalism are approached topologically
rather than geometrically which is what
we needed for the kind of vanishing
point type
math art in the spatial setting
well I think their their approach
geometrically eventually and and that's
really what the the session in September
will be about it's how to how to start
with this
very topological picture
where we're only talking about
uh
interactions
of
in a sense
interactions and time but but outside of
space
and layer of spatial structure on top of
that
and this is
I I think this is particularly
interesting in this active inference
context because
yeah
it immediately raises biological
questions about
um
the
the ability of different organisms to
layer space on their experience and
hence locate themselves if you will
within some sort of of perceived world
awesome Dean and then back to Andre for
the last minutes
and then please continue
sorry so Chris is it from the from the
pure neophyte perspective that I have is
it okay to say that it's not just
a flipping of of position of words that
somewhere processing that availability
and processing somewhere in the
classical sense where am I it's the it's
our ability to fuse those as you
mentioned we can we can slow down we can
stabilize we can see that relationship
or is it about spin
I think the former
rights spin is a very convenient
abstraction for talking about
binary encoding
and we have this felt sense of spin but
the the sense it's it's use in physics
is very much an abstraction I mean the
difference between a proton and neutron
is a spin variable
awesome under you can in last minutes
take it where you need
also on mute and continue
can you guys hear me now
well so let's uh hope that I have a time
for Chris to address a couple things so
just to conclude the slides
um and then hopefully we get to say a
few words on Quantum Darwinism so
towards the end the slides
um appear to start pivoting towards the
next subject which is space on time
and here in particular we see the
earlier slide uh showcasing the log
protocol where you can you can you can
notice that half of it has been cut
and that has has been moved to the
Future so here we don't have uh two
sectors of power let's communicating but
rather Alice communicating with its
future
still you have the classical and the
quantum Channel now one question that I
brought up I remember
and uh in in the lecture and maybe we
can expand on a little more was
exactly what is the difference between
this Quantum and the classical Channel
part
um something I heard Chris say is that
it is crucial for the quantum channel to
be coherent so this is going to be some
sort of unitary scattering Evolution
that is
completely independent of everything
else going on
uh is that correct or should be in
theory
and ask yes yeah and and I suppose just
like earlier the classical the classical
channel is is the part that takes time
and free energy expenditure now uh my
question uh to you Chris is
on no no not the not the channels in the
middle but the ticks on either side of
the boundaries that have been broken
down and separated
in terms of an external time what's
what's up with those ticks from one
sector to the other of the boundary so
in q1 for example the allow the lower
CRF sector that's that amount to a state
was prepared the upper one was I made a
memory record of that state is that
that's what it is right
yeah
okay so uh in in the lower sector we
both had
a preparation and a measurements and a
measurement was recorded classically
here
that's all there is
yeah so so preparation and measurement
are are effectively the same process
um and you can think of uh
in A1 of t
what A1 is doing
is uh
from from an operational point of view
uh she's
preparing an instrument
and turning it on
she's she's creating an initial state
and she's simultaneously
encoding a memory someplace
um
in her head or or on a piece of paper of
what does Preparation conditions were
because it's only with respect to the
memory of what the preparation
conditions were
that the later measurement is Meaningful
so
um
to let's let's go back to just preparing
a spin
uh right in at T
she may uh
set the angle of some polarization
filter
that defines a propagating beam of
photons
and at t plus delta T she measures
something about what those photons are
doing but the measurement is only
meaningful with respect to her memory
of what the polarization setting that
prepared the photons was
so the
effectively what's going on in the
quantum channel is an experiment
and it's
it's
the the classical information that's
preserved in this classical channel that
makes the experiment meaningful or
interpretable or informative yeah for
sure yeah that makes perfect sense and
and preparation of measurement this dies
back to an earlier question we had what
both happened simultaneously at the same
like
um uh degree of Freedom At The Boundary
or do we have preparation at the lower
bounds are the top of one the only
reason you
so
yeah when when can one can think of that
operator Mi if you remember the
decomposition of the hamiltonian as as
preparing or measuring that it's just a
matter of interpretation
uh you know effectively is it acting to
the left or acting to the right
yeah okay yeah yeah yeah
and then
um before we get to quantumeric person
that's uh more of a spatial instead of
attack theme I wanted to ask uh yet
another question between this one on my
classes so the quantum channels thus
involves some sort of
Time Revolution you know it's this
unitary
you know portion that is uh sorry this
portion that is evolving unitarily with
no interference from the outside
uh however as you said for this
experiment to make sense you need to
have a classical memory of of that
experiment most prepared plus that means
that that classical guy on top is uh
aesthetic there's no time flowing it
uh well this actually gets back to the
talk by suskin that we were talking
about before we started here uh that you
you kindly referred me to
um
part of part of this classical memory
is uh
memory for what counts as a classical
clock
and we'll we'll actually get to this
again in the September session
but if you if you think again about
doing an experiment
uh in which a state is prepared and then
it's measured
uh this Quantum process is a process
Through Time
with respect to some
uh classical clock
that actually provides the time
coordinate for the experiment
so
this
this classical clock is some
external reference frame
that
that A1 here in this notation is is
using as part of her classical memory
right again uh it's a Memory because
it's something that's assumed not to
change
and and this is
this will be kind of the heart of the
discussion in September that that time
and memory and object persistence are
all different names for this same
assumption that we make about the world
um
thank you Chris
thank you I I am going to have to
disappear so
um only for now though
yeah only for now I I will I will
nonetheless persist someplace
thank you Chris
come on Chris okay awesome
thanks very much well measure you later
okay
um enter if you wanted to
drop any other
cues or clues or
bring us a little bit of a preparation
for where we're going to be heading in
lecture five that would be pretty cool
uh sure so I mean I I'm a little aware
of what's coming in lecture five
um
until about uh space sometime and how
space may be sorry time may be a little
more fundamental than space for reasons
that Chris will show
um
has a lot to do with the notion of how
you define a clock as in we need to
think hard
about what what what are the verb
minimum ingredients
for you to talk about the existence of a
clock uh these are deep fundamental
almost philosophical questions that are
overlooked and the good news and that's
the sasking talk that Chris and I were
referring to referring to is that other
people especially in the high energy
Community are also looking into these
questions which is very reassuring so
I'm talking
uh Harlow Etc they are
there's a recent talk on YouTube where
they talk about
what does it mean for something to be a
clot you know how that's how long does a
clock last and and then Chris will also
talk about space
and and the punchline of it will be
that
um
there's obviously a physics approach to
emerging space-time which is very very
technical and and so on
but
from what I understood I mean I I have
the interesting to talk my first my
thoughts myself first
um is that there is a parallel
biological approach as to how we learn
our space-time so from uh developmental
psychology point of view
um
influence and I suppose all kinds of
animals are not born uh fully equipped
to perceive space-time hence the
necessity of things like clay and so on
so they can find correlations between uh
motor inputs and visual inputs right and
eventually things like the mirror test
which is non-trivial no no no no no no
human born is born
uh passing the mirror test already
so that implies that at least
biologically it is non-trivial and it
takes a few steps until you get to have
that sort of
a space spatial awareness right
now the interesting part of this for me
personally is with the with the physics
side of it is and uh I I'm no expert by
any means but I think the gist of it
might might have to do something with
Quantum error correction uh ads EFT and
so on
um there was a bit of a teaser about
quantumeric correction here in this
slides uh but yeah I mean that's that's
about all I can say
but very looking forward to the biology
also
yeah cool
Harris any last thoughts or anything you
want to point towards
basically I would like to thank everyone
for inviting me
I really enjoyed it
the whole uh
live stream
I hope we have made some progress
and looking forward to
the next
live streams number five and number six
so that's about it thank you everyone